across the country americans are
remembering those who lost their lives
defending our country
bradley blackburn reports
president biden marked memorial day
solemnly laying a wreath at the tomb of
the unknown soldier
afterward he talked about the sacrifice
so many have made to defend our country
we're gathered at this sacred place
in this solemn hour to engage in the
most
fundamental of undertakings the right
of remembrance the president urged
americans not to let the fallen heroes
deaths be in vain
democracy itself is in peril
here at home and around the world he
called on americans to remember
what unites us empathy is the fuel
of democracy our willingness to see each
other
not as enemy as neighbors even we
disagree to understand
here in new york veterans are gathering
to reflect and remember together
in person something they could not do
last year
you never forget never forget the guys
that gave up their lives
for this country intrepid veterans say
they lost 150 crew members in the last
year
many of them died from covid 19. bradley
blackburn
cbs news new york